gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out if they're yours to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash i'm
your host dave foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antootie's basement good news starts a
brand new job monday okay yep gonna be
mulen for a little while
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he's international businessman let me
tell you something gang the next time
you're reaching for a best pal do
yourself a favor make it a kippy because
it comes with a bunch of zeros
give it up for kj kevin james ryan
really hamming me up at the end of the
[ __ ] month huh i know how you i know
how you uh once that patreon process
that youtube money's about to hit what
do you mean i got my room cleaned and
all my chores done what's up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube as you know
those numbers are true cook and baby and
then obviously patreon.com the greatest
website of all time it's going to go
down to history believe it or not uh you
can sign up you get bonus content ayg
hard feelings live streams the whole
nine yards check it the [ __ ] out and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good we love them you
love them t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes everybody
hey team i'm excited we got the hottest
guy in school i hope he hasn't
he is dreamy oh man getting a ride home
from this kid
he drives it he drives a t-top for sure
this [ __ ] kid your mom's hanging out
the front window on a low top no [ __ ]
okay we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest and i
mean incredibly special guest back with
us again today family episode we got a
little company in the building he's the
host of the boys cast podcast you know
him you love him give it up for mr ryan
long everybody boys in the place also i
have been uh recently telling people i'm
going by uh kevin james ryan oh is that
your name now yeah
as long as i get some of those youtube
checks i don't mind ryan kevin james
that's what i'm talking about
why is your middle name kevin yeah it is
now
this guy's stealing my identity yeah no
turn into a sociopath real quick yeah
i've been chatting with the high school
kids
no i don't use my name to chat with the
high school that old high school thing
was accurate it was just recently
just a couple of weeks ago i didn't
catch him the first round i go back now
i go did you guys see my youtube videos
standing there with a boom mic or
something
you got a football underneath yourself
oh good stuff buddy how are you man boys
are in the building yeah we're having i
was gonna tell you guys that we had a
garbage controversy on our podcast last
week lay it on out so danny paul's chuck
has been going off about how he thinks
that after you finish with condoms you
flush him down the toilet
which i thought for a while is what you
did as well if you're a hit man
yeah they jam up the plumbing i've heard
this we said he was
and he's like saying he's flushing them
i mean his are smaller but
i don't know
give me a close call barely a mouthful
no he's he's been flushing his whole
life and he's had clogged toilets and we
found it this is why and everyone in the
comments was like this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then someone told us that
there was this one guy that his he was a
plumber and this guy's toilet was so
clogged and then they unclogged it with
all these condoms and he's like well i
don't use condoms with my wife oh
god damn that's i think i found out
that his wife yeah that's weird well you
wouldn't use condoms with your wife yeah
that's crazy that's you're that plumber
do you still charge the guy what do you
do well hey buddy this one's on the
house
that's the guy that she was [ __ ]
daniel polish chuck co-host of the boys
cast watching them uh hold on high
school you're in a pinch if you're at
your high school girlfriend or college
girlfriend's parents house yeah you
don't want to leave that evidence around
just out of respect you don't want to
throw it in the old man's face it's like
yeah well you guys were a christmas shop
when i was home on the couch doing [ __ ]
to your daughter you know i said you
wrap it in a piece of toilet paper and
take it because that's because you can't
trust the group
take it i've one hundred percent done
that yeah well because what the what are
you dexterity i've taken them as well
you've taken that
what you know well that's after when you
well like yeah then she goes where is it
and then you pull it out of the girl's
ear
not your nose
it's a fun bit for the next time you see
her yeah
uh i've definitely i've taken i've done
everything with them i've thrown them
off a bridge whatever you need i treat
it like a [ __ ] like a gun without the
cereal put one on concrete and threw it
in the river
yeah you got i mean yeah trash can if
that's applicable i thought you you wrap
it up in a lot of toilet paper and just
put it in the trash can the trash can if
you're if you're an adult if you're an
adult no but that that's the thing like
on the tours and stuff like that you
can't always trust the i mean that's why
drake was like yeah
he puts so drake puts hot sauce on the
condoms to kill the sperms
and then if the girl tries to first of
all kills his parents but then also
there's a little extra punishment for if
she tries to get it up there
it happens this is like not a made-up
thing it happened
a lot of especially in the past
basketball players ball players
that's not happening to kj in raleigh on
a tuesday all right they see those i'm
buried by the way what are we talking
about they see those patreon members
i love you babe yeah i was like he paid
for this [ __ ] i wasn't i wasn't thinking
like that
we're not on the [ __ ]
this is hypothetical yeah yeah totally
hot t-bone zoom in totally hypothetical
it really is this isn't that clip i'm
just i'm just blown away
listen i'll give it to the kid but the
arrogance of you you're taking it oh it
isn't it's very i'm not taking it i'm
not taking it because i think she's
gonna use it i'm taking to go home and
paint a tree
too also i jerked off she wants half of
your chevy lumina
do you guys do you guys tie
i don't tie it off no that's crazy well
no i obviously tie it off because you
know dude who are you guys seriously
what do we tie what do we die what's
going on i don't know it's just a setup
tie what man what
you tie the condom off of where you
throw it but a real g move is you leave
it on and you go
i go to the bank do whatever you know i
run my i run my errands with it
you start getting soft you put an
elastic around you go now oh rubber band
on there i see you oh man a soft pp and
a condo and a used condom that's a tough
luck yeah yikes
i go from saturday night to sunday
morning real quick
[Laughter]
it's bad yeah it's not a party down
there
um what you've never you've had to flush
one before i listen i said
if you're it shouldn't be operational
the plumber community was having a field
they were not happy yeah no yeah it'll
[ __ ] it'll clog you up get stuck in a
p-trap shout out to the plumber's local
but here's the thing as a you know he
hoops it
[Laughter]
well that's why you tie it up you know
you don't want that stuff getting loose
i throw it over the telephone wire you
go like you're like like a pair of
sneaks that's you at the airport getting
busted and there you go what's in your
ass this drugs you go i can explain it
she's like there's gold diggers out
there sir
i'm trying to trap me officer
i have a podcast
have you ever heard of patreon
we do pretty well over there i don't
want one of these [ __ ] coming after me
anyways
now you gentlemen will excuse me
i need some more rubbers
i gotta be in st myers florida in two
hours
hold on as a discretionary measure in
certain situations coming up yes as an
adult living a single life you know
doing your own thing
flushing it
is crazy sure yeah
either one of you bozos taking it to go
like a [ __ ] doggy bag
is crazy
and [ __ ] circus jim over here
tying them up
is nuts tying them up's pretty bonkers
dude well then you pin it to your wall
and write the girl's name over top give
it to the bearded
you put that over the beer funnel
like they're batting gloves it's the
world's grossest water balloon yeah that
goes on the [ __ ] bud light mantle oh
no yeah
i've never uh i've never taught i've
taken it i i'm i'm assuming i have in
this first of all how much length do you
got in that thing that you can make a
full knot
i get like halfway through that thing oh
i can make a giraffe dog what are you
talking about
toby's double knot in it
i can barely make an earthworm
um
there's supposed to be extra room at the
end right
[Laughter]
i mean that's for jesus
leave room for jesus in the condom right
that's what that means well yeah exactly
um
yeah no i i mean i wasn't like
i think
he's stressed out about this now though
i'm trying to remember i feel like i for
sure have taken i just can't recall you
might have a kid out there you're just
realizing
someone else getting cut into this
patreon all of a sudden
cut this
uh
yeah no i'm sure i've taken it at some
point to dispose because like i didn't
know what to do with i don't want to
flush it down the toilet i don't want to
you know i don't know maybe there wasn't
a trash can or something he just feels
like very stealth you go in and out
without a trace man yeah it's really
weird like is that biggie smalls so you
know yeah you gotta go you can't trace
the semen
thrown in a dumpster behind an arby's or
something but just any remote chance
remote chance something happens to you
what was in his pockets they go through
your pie yeah use condoms i mean that
that's that's from two weeks ago that's
a tough that's conspiracy theory
if he had four use condoms
it was a long day
uh yeah that's kept one in his hat
how do we start talking about this
danny paul i saw you guys i saw the
tweet about it oh the flushing of the
condoms yeah yeah to do a public apology
but i feel like it was the garbage move
so that's why i was like
you shouldn't be doing it i will say
this though i know this is gonna sound
bad
um environmentally but when it comes to
stuff like that i'm not worried about
that like you know they say like don't
flush the wipes the the butt wipes
because they do this or
you know don't put bacon grease oh that
one's true the only thing i know they're
true
no no no no i'm not saying they're not
trying to go you know they go don't uh
wipe with [ __ ] paper towels or
whatever and you go okay well i'm gonna
do it i say that you know you meet in
the middle where you go i'll tell you
what i'll rip it in two yeah oh yeah
yeah you gotta do that yeah you got it
it gives you more grip it's all right
that's how you're meeting in the middle
yeah that one can come back to haunt you
though that really you you there's a
instant gratification with that where
that like affects
like two flushes of that
and your toilet could be clogged you
could be jammed up yeah you don't want
to do that at someone else's house you
end up like ben stiller
nine movies back-to-back issues
oh god i [ __ ] again
uh have you ever clogged a public or
like somebody else's toilet i had a
pretty [ __ ] good one too i was at my
buddy's uh step uh step parents house
and his stepsister comes running out the
[ __ ] toilet's dripping everywhere
there's [ __ ] everywhere oh and i was
there like did everybody know that you
were everybody knew it was me and it was
very like hold on her dad her dad
the dad kind of being like all right uh
it's not your fault oh my god
i would have ran away dude i would have
ran out the front door hold on watch
that mic too because they're not that
strong you gotta lean into it a little
bit oh yeah yeah but uh
you pay me this picture did you not
flush
or did you flush too much toilet paper
that's how it always hold on did you did
you clog it and walk away like nothing
happened no no no no no did you make an
attempt to clean it i think that i
i think i've in this specific scenario
i think i've flushed
you thought everything was cool i didn't
know it was an issue that's not really
his responsibility and then next thing
you know there's a you know 14 year old
stepsister running out like
her pants are wet she's singing a
different duck
oh man the fact that it's a kid makes it
way worse it was it was a rough like i
was the it was like an uncle they would
have been like yeah i think they could
have anyone else other than me because
if anyone else they could just yell at
them with me it was a very awkward
scenario i'm sure i bet a few of those
were but i don't know i my first offense
to the dad would have been yo when i
left it all flushed
so i don't know what the kid's talking
about that's [ __ ] shoddy plumbing in
here but it's also like i thought if i
was me now i would have those kind of
cajones to be like i am [ __ ] clogged
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you clogged you know
what i mean at the time i was coming
right here you little [ __ ] i was
i was caught off guard at the time i go
okay what
yeah exactly yeah okay and plus i
thought that you did your business you
flushed it it was clogged and you
thought i might have just dipped that
yeah i made that break for it i probably
would have went home and never came back
you never seen the person again yeah you
got it yeah yeah
that's for a plunger me and my
where me and my body were with two girls
at the girl's house and the girl took a
[ __ ] clogged the place pretty bad how
have we ever [ __ ]
basically just like uh i can't remember
she had some nickname forever that's
basically all it
uh came ship the [ __ ] water hits the
floor you got real problems we went we
went up there was like survive i guess
it was like 12 guys and 12 girls were
like in college i think we all went up
we rented a house in the poconos and my
my one boy vinnie with the skinny it was
always like you had to dip off because
there was only like one or two bathrooms
we were up there for like three days
[ __ ] drinking to be a partying for
three four days so at some point you
know you're it's it's everybody's
getting hemmed up and my one body
clogged the toilet twice in the weekend
and like it was so clearly him because
he would disappear for like an hour and
a
half
everyone's like where's
the dog who's [ __ ] on the rug yeah and
then like
behind the cooler
cuts to him he's in the corner and stuff
yeah client yeah once you get once
you're in someone else's bathroom
working the plunger you're [ __ ]
like it's like it's like putting a body
in half let me feel like how did i get
here
but let me tell you something
um having the plunger
really solves 90 of the problems it's
usually never that clogged thank god
there is plungers you know how many
times i've done that in a social
situation yeah but i'm like this is
going to be
so embarrassing and i'm looking around
the [ __ ] bathroom well it's also like
can you find the plunger in the back of
the thing wrapped in a [ __ ] shoprite
bag oh thanks always wrapped up [ __ ]
working but it's always like i'm like
[ __ ] clooney on er like come on god
damn it
not tonight
follow my watch live
live
dude i'm going
you know it only really matters on away
games right if you're at someone's house
or if you clog your own tooth you move
yeah at home i'll leave it there that's
the way how are you not like how are you
not taking precautions like how are you
not courtesy flushing how are you not
being like all right don't use too much
toilet paper like encouragement you
don't get to see it oh you're right
you're a little weird these kids these
canucks are a little bonkers
i like to take a look at it you know
[Laughter]
i didn't buy a ticket not to see the
show you know what i mean yeah yeah i
gotta get the photo for the album
senator's a trainer
god it's good stuff
so he made a formal apology okay yeah
it's good to the community it's good
to the plumbers but never apologize to a
plumber just trying to be a better
plumber want you to be stupid they want
you to mess up they want to come in and
i think i get paid they want to come in
and find a shoebox full of condoms
[ __ ] stuff no they gotta act
indignant the same way that like a guy
that wants to [ __ ] a girl and her
boyfriend's being an [ __ ] he goes oh
that's so crappy
yeah yeah i really go chi-ching who was
it um
it was
it's the third house she's done it to
she always calls that plumber it was
kate from bar stool who she lived in a
house no she lived in a house for four
years and put all the condoms behind
like just dropped them between her bed
and the wall after they were done oh
yeah and then her dad came to help her
move her out and like pulled the bed
back and there was just like
four years of her you know being
promiscuous and
he's like she's like she didn't say he
didn't say a word and then we were like
we were in the car after like three
hours from the pennsylvania turnpike and
he just started crying
yeah she's like it was like i've never
felt so bad for her she could have just
been it was one guy
yeah no i mean
she said she was living living a little
rowdy at the time that it was you know
clearly not one guy or something
tossing him behind the bed is nuts
that's crazy for an extended period of
time yes of course
i mean what's an extended period of time
i i mean listen i i look at it i look at
it
the way everybody does on sunday night
you make sure that you clean up all
evidence of anything you did [ __ ] up
that weekend
so you're saying that's like that that's
in the heat of the moment you throw it
off yeah you throw it behind there you
got it the next day yeah
where you put it in a ziploc bag and
take it home and throw it in the cigar
pop it in the freezer and then you
shatter it
it wants popsicles
couple of psychos kippy let's talk about
athletic greens athletic greens athletic
greens i'm not just a pusher i'm also a
user yeah ag-1 loving yeah it's good
stuff i really listen
coffee was giving me anxiety okay i have
this in the morning on an empty stomach
i have it while i work out instead of
instead of a water i'm telling you it it
it it does more than the water yeah it
like of course gets you going it's like
a high-powered multi-vitamin it's got
everything you need it's fantastic plus
the gut health which i really wanted
that's why the founder started he was
having issues yeah and then he got into
that um it's fantastic guys it costs
less than three dollars a day and if
you're investing in your health it's
cheaper than a cup of cold brew athletic
creams has over seven thousand five star
reviews recommended by professional
athletes scientists the whole nine yards
it's lifestyle friendly whether you're
keto paleo vegan dairy-free gluten-free
they got you covered no gmos no
chemicals it's all natural baby yeah i'm
telling you try it for a month while
you're working out i guarantee you want
to do it for another month yes good
stuff to make it easy athletic greens is
going to give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is go to
athleticgreens.com garbage again one
more time that's athleticgreens.com
garbage to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance do it
yeah okay let's talk about bumbas bon
baz boom boss baby let me tell you
something about bomber's gang yeah their
mission real simple make the most
comfortable ever close ever then match
every item sold and donate it yes so
you're literally when you buy bumbus
you're helping someone else out yes
you're giving to someone in need there's
a good peeps over there at bombas man
that's cool oh yeah uh they designed
their sock shirts and underwear to be
the clothes you can't wait to put on
every day uh everything they make feel
soft seamless tagless has a luxurious
cozy feel and i'm big into luxurious
stuff big into the cozy on you yeah so
um there's a pair of bomba socks for
everything you do they come in a ton of
options uh comfy performance styles for
every sport activity that keeps you
moving the boma's t-shirts are made with
thoughtful design features like
invisible seams soft fabrics the perfect
weight so they just hang they hang just
right uh go to bomas.com garbage you get
twenty percent off your first purchase
that's bombas b o m b a s dot com
garbage for twenty percent off bombas
dot com slash garbage do it now back to
the show
all right let's get into some questions
ryan thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with us gang as you know
when you sign up for the old patreon
there get a question read on the air
with the boys yeah um this one is from
somebody who wants to remain nameless
it's not even that steamy is it garbage
to consider yourself a d1 college
athlete if you were the mascot
i would say for sure is it garbage or
like sleazy it's we i
i guess it depends on how you're
claiming it if you're in a barbie like
yeah by the way i don't think i don't
say sleazy in like a derogatory way yeah
i was like walking to the party
yeah let's take our condoms with us i
mean you're obviously who are you saying
that to like impress a group of guys you
just obviously you're trying to impress
a chick yeah i don't think you're trying
to impress a good another group like
football players like i know
i know the struggle buddy i was the lion
you know what i mean
did you ever try to jump through a
flaming hoop talking to gronkowski at a
bar
yeah i guess you'd be using it you know
to pick up trying to pick up a chick in
a bar of like yeah or maybe you claim to
it to the glory days yeah just as the
life flex um i say
however you want to feel about it he is
they are division one athletes they get
scholarships they're [ __ ] highly paid
at a professional level the mascots it's
those big schools they're yeah they make
good money
they like work their way up the mass got
certificates [ __ ] yeah they start out
scholarships come on yeah no you have to
yeah because it's a scholarship if
you're a high school like they're like
gymnasts i don't i don't know i don't
know if that this is the way it is now
stop if you're if you were a high school
kid in the 90s and nobody thought of
this kid i went to high school with
became the [ __ ] mascot uh for us
then went on the [ __ ] college and was
the mascot there ended up [ __ ]
working for the houston rockets no way
it was the rocket can you believe it for
like 20 years something like that
killed it
there's a whole team behind that stuff
yeah but i mean there's only like you
know what is there roughly 30
professional know i'm saying that's what
i said if you would have thought it was
like a hundred of those positions i
thought they threw like a concession guy
in a [ __ ] costume jimmy you're up get
the hat will you
randy's back is acting up yeah i didn't
know it was get the fanatic yeah that's
like they make business yeah
can you get can you pull up a salary on
mascots uh
i from memory i remember that benny the
bull makes around 250k
250. i thought i thought that was a
different bull every day like i didn't
know
does it make a wish kid they shot the
old one
they do they do corporate gigs and they
get paid out the ass how are they doing
good at the corporate gigs oh yeah well
i know somebody who if you're having a
corporate gig and you don't have the san
diego chicken you're [ __ ] losing
corporate gigs are so weird for those
like because what do you really do you
just sort of bop around like i know a
guy was a magician he'd do corporate
gigs and they'd hire him to do hand
magic so you kind of just walk up to
people that weren't interested and be
like oh pick a card and everyone's like
it's like hey i'm trying to steal the
deal over here which is so strange this
guy the people that run companies that
like why would you want to do this thing
that makes it awkward for everybody they
think people are like i think someone
gets put in charge of the committee and
they're like i don't know what do you
got okay get a [ __ ] magician let's
just get this thing over with they think
it would be good it's the same as like
comment have you ever done corporates of
course
have any of them gone well you're not
really a corporate puppeteer unless have
gone well unless it's like a tattoo shop
i went with a body used
no i've done a fair amount he killed
probably the bounty hunter
whole family loved them
the corporates they go fine if uh if
it's only like 10 15. when it starts
pushing 35 40 cleaning that's right yeah
and
you don't have it really the clean
material oh no yeah peanuts are weird
he was this guy jj who we tour with he's
like the raunchiest dude and he was
doing some he was bombing so it's you
know you get to that thing where you go
[ __ ] i'm bombing like if i i could do
better if i start doing my dirty [ __ ]
but i will be in [ __ ] trouble sure
and he decided [ __ ] it i'd rather lose
this than bomb because this is very very
painful
i gotta support that i gotta support the
decision it's an admiral choice i've
done it right it's like whatever they're
gonna say to me after is not as bad as
what's happening right now yes i need a
[ __ ] lifeline let me say [ __ ]
yeah so he starts doing this joke about
how some girl has a [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
baseball bat and then the guy goes the
guy who's running it just looks at me
because i'm [ __ ] open for him he just
looks me he goes get him off
get him on stage and then uh
he's and then apparently there's a
difference between like dirty and like
yeah being a baseball bat and he was
doing the octo to go
oh yeah so he's and this guy said he
almost got fired over
yeah dude sometimes
probably loses his job
i did a fundraiser one time i had to
work clean i was bombing i mean i sucked
at the time and i was bombing and like i
went to do a joke and i realized it was
dirty i'm like i can't do that when it's
dirty or whatever and they were like do
it i'm like all right and then that
bumped
i'm like maybe i'm just not good
dirty clean i don't know
well that's the oldest trick in the book
is because you always say what do you
want they're no they're not going to be
like yeah we're [ __ ] yeah oh yeah and
by the way if 80 people say clean and
one guy says dirty you go you got it
the people have spoken
that's very true that's funny it's
the oldest trick in the book but yeah no
the corporates uh remember you stopped
i took you to do one um he was like yeah
just do like eight minutes up top and i
did about 35 seconds of bombing i'm like
you guys ready to get this show started
got the [ __ ] out of there
magic is sort of the trashiest job like
i'm the one friend he used to do magic
and he would always be trying to do the
street tricks he used to walk around
with his shoe untied and then you'd go
uh you were like oh your shoe's untied
and then he would go
and i would tie the shirt oh my god and
then people be like all right get this
guy out of here
[Laughter]
whoever showed you how to do it
but chris angel's uh tricks these days
like all those new guys like even david
blaine their tricks are just like i'm
gonna have a guy punch me in the face
five hundred times i'm gonna freeze my
balls off he's hearing tricks he just
holds his breath buddy get a coat a
trick and you're like what's the trick
he's like you go yo i put a sword
through my [ __ ] arm you know what's
the trick he's like it just hurts a lot
he's taking the pain i've seen david
blaine do some pretty cool [ __ ] oh yeah
all yeah of course they're top magicians
they have all those people in the dr but
the new the new school like magic thing
is like it's like stunts it's like yeah
it's more like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] he
goes i'm gonna go stand on the roof for
three days
that's literally what it is it's like
weird [ __ ] have you ever been to a show
magic show yeah i've seen a couple yeah
there's one guy that's a buddy of mine i
went to his place i'll talk about you
jokes they're all like kind of half
comedians to be honest how big was the
audience i've seen a few times but one
with like 500 people really yeah and
they killed too like they get they do
because they don't have
and they also don't have to be their
jokes
yeah they're just like
street jokes essentially they're
smashing dude i saw uh
a lot of freaking jokes did i ever tell
you this you saw siegfried and roy yeah
back in the day
uh
uh it was they i don't know how they did
it they were in the stage and then they
ended up one of them was on our table
like the lights went out and the lights
came on and he was standing over my
chicken fingers and we were like how the
[ __ ] did he get here that quick i still
don't know how he did it
it was like lights went off for five
seconds and he was 500 yards away and he
ended up standing on our table nude
i was a tiger but still
he
[Laughter]
couldn't get tickets for carrot top
though that's trashy the top david
copperfield he called him the top
we're here to see the top david
copperfield was classy he was the last
class you want i think magician he was a
gentleman yeah six feet in room is
pretty classy so the bloodbath
i never even like even as like a sat
like copper will be like i'm gonna make
the empire state building disappear and
it's like a seven-year-old i'm like no
you're not
you're not all you're doing is taking
knight rider off for a week you're
[ __ ] killing me yeah i'm gonna make
the statue of liberty disappear i'm like
you i don't know anything but you are
not doing that the tv magicians are even
crazier because theirs was like okay now
i'm going to be on the top of statue and
you're like i know that you cut yeah
like i'm watching this wasn't a whole
shot it's not live on one shot like how
stupid do you think i am i'm gonna
teleport i'm gonna teleport in a split
second
right after these words and now i'm
black and white
i had a body who dead serious believe
that chris angel walked on water in like
the bellagio fountain and i'm like no he
didn't man he's like we didn't explain
it i'm like i don't [ __ ] glass i
don't know everybody everybody got swept
up in that [ __ ] in the early 2000s
everybody hook line and sinker yeah all
that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] well it's good if you do
it like once or twice but then when you
have a weekly show it's like all right
i'm starting to see the seams in this
you know what i mean
the one he just makes pizza
yeah then the caterer is out that
[ __ ] thing those vegas clubs are
pretty fed up with his nonsense probably
right now
yeah when he disappears and he's sitting
on the cooker he goes yeah just four
minutes i'm in the kitchen
i need somewhere to wait
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyways that's pretty crazy that mascots
are [ __ ] that is yeah that's exactly
how we got there i mean
i would think that i would think that
like anybody who's not you know half an
[ __ ] wouldn't be going around saying
um you know yeah there is one athlete
you know what i mean saying [ __ ] like
that if somebody asked or whatever it's
like oh you were the mascot of michigan
that's pretty cool yeah but pimping
using that
language you're kind of an [ __ ] but
on paper technically they are division
one athletes the question it really is
did it work like did did any girl have
you ever smashed because of the mascot i
think you i think you it would be cooler
if you were if all you have to say
instead of saying individual athlete
you're like yeah i was the [ __ ]
boilermaker at purdue or whatever you
know what i mean why is that i don't
know i didn't get that the boilermaker
the the guy i don't know what purdue is
either oh
they make a hell of a chicken i know
that much spoiler
psychology i know it's a college
football team
i'm saying you wouldn't have to say
division one athlete it'd be better to
lead with the mascot sure i get it yeah
sure does that make sense yeah of course
i'll just say hey i was yeah yeah i
guess uh
i would assume this is probably coming
up in drunk [ __ ] arguments of like
you don't know i was a d1 athlete and
you're like i don't know about that well
that's probably where it's coming up at
i would give it to him well there's also
a part of i found a whole article about
uh
college mascots should be part of the
theater district or something you know
100 not athletes
that's pretty good
part of it is they have to maintain a
secret identity yeah they can't wait
what what come on yeah get kidnapped by
the other teamers that means face idle
kidnapping
it's a plot of them
we lost five bulldogs before we realized
that
you don't know what purdue is or the
poison maker i didn't know boilermaker
jesus it's a shot and a beer a tui yeah
that's how i know a boilermaker's shot
i'm gonna be honest i don't know what a
mascot is i'm just trying to rip here
i'm canadian you know they're illegal in
canada they're trying to keep up
they're government employees up there
they work nine to four every day and
that's it
ah
that's great
i had a buddy who uh
used to say he was in there he was the
kicker in the arena football league and
there was like out of the bar there's no
real way to prove that wrong he's like
yeah i'm the kicker on the philly soul
and they were like are you he's like
yeah and he was like billed enough and
they were like all right i guess so
to love girls we were the bass player in
maroon 5.
you could pull that off
yeah just picking weird bands just
playing with a pick like flipping it in
your fingers i just love underselling
like you're not you don't even pick like
the coolest guy
just did a studio session with michael
stipe you know yeah i was the third
guitar player in arcade fire so yeah
uh all right this one's in the same vein
of the magic have you ever been to a
this is from dan have you ever gone to a
free concert
that like a radio show put on
like one of those big festival type
things like the governor's ball
governor balls isn't free though oh it's
expensive yeah uh like 100 one palooza
they do like you know yeah like radio
stations or whoever will put on like
shitty festivals or like a [ __ ]
fairground or something yeah i think i
mean i played in bands for like 10 years
so i was like what were you a guitarist
not drums but i sang in that band but i
probably done a million a drummer singer
yeah but then we had a drama really what
are you don henley you're saying you're
singing from behind the kids i was doing
jefferson oh that was always a tough
look i hate to bring it to you well
that's why we got the drummer it was a
tough look
dude when one of the remember that they
got rid of that [ __ ] mtv real early but
for a little while there was a couple of
dudes hanging out
it was don henley they had phil
collinsville collins did it but it's
like somebody had to be someone's gonna
be moving around give me a mascot
knock this off with the drummer sing it
they had a big when sars was happening
they had a thing in toronto called sars
stock oh my god these [ __ ] canadians
are nuts
come on out this airstock you know
it'll be a real hoot
wear your mask
welcome back to heart disease of palupa
everybody oh here's even better the
biggest bit i'll tell you what starts a
second but the biggest uh band in canada
is tragically hip they're called right
it's the hugest band of canada like
basically like every cottage fire you
know anthem right and the second biggest
band is a cover band called the
practically hip
it does like almost as big as numbers
they're bigger than the actual band wow
that's weird practically
just numbers but the stars stock was
apparently i think there was like a
stage issue and a bunch of people died
and they were trying to raise money for
stars and the rolling stones played
that's pretty good and the blues
brothers the biggest the biggest concert
that ever came to toronto sort of but
then coming next cloverfest
[Laughter]
and justin timberlake
what was there there's a big festival at
starsfest yeah
was it was that 98 or 2001. which one
was it 2003. i was at the original one
way better
and also rush this is the programming's
all over the place i'm telling you it's
the biggest festival security by the
hell's angels
[Laughter]
they are they legitimately that's not
untrue they did have security by the
hells angels which was a part of the
controversy when all this stuff was
happening they didn't have like the
right union guys because there was stage
issues and all this stuff the hell's
angels are still around in 2003 oh dude
they're still around and in canada do
you think they disappeared i don't know
they call back they're all french this
sounds like pagan [ __ ] apparently the
hell's angels are all in quebec and a
lot of them got locked up there's a lot
of them they just had they used to have
uh
by pagans did you mean the other biker
gang yeah
i'm a hell no i'm kidding
uh
i they used to have in the east village
they used to have a huge [ __ ] like uh
brownstone i don't know if they were
still working security in venues
i don't know
what oh yeah they're probably prospects
but i know it's one of those you know
how every italian guy is kind of like
like a bit connected every you know
every biker is like you know my boys
boys kind of i just watched a video
where these like three dudes like kind
of started their own
gang like they had like a patch on
that's a big thing i started gang as an
adult well yeah they were just kind of
like hey
we ride together yeah we'll start doing
stick-ups see they're like hey we ride
together you know maybe meth who knows
yeah just friends just friends i'm like
yeah but like they were like living into
like the sons of anarchy like you know
and they had the pa they had came up
with their own patches or whatever so
they were losers
and they some they're at a gas station
filling up and like these [ __ ] six
you know real [ __ ] gangsters rolled
up and puck and pulled their numbers ron
perlman pulled up
on a hug
started cleaning house uh my dad like
take that [ __ ] patch off they're like
who like
this yeah and it's all videotaped like
all right man we were just hanging out
we're like middle-aged guys or whatever
yeah yeah really what if it's their own
patch why can't they have it that means
well then it's like i think in like the
gang thing it's on site like you're
you're you're flying colors we're flying
colors like are you about that life type
thing they don't have to always fight
they can't pass each other while they're
grabbing while they're filling up and
getting themselves i'm not the mayor of
these [ __ ] gangs i don't know i'm
just telling you they bitched them out
in the [ __ ] gas station and the video
was like the blood's in the crips yeah
exactly of like you know you're you're
claiming you're in a motorcycle hell's
angels and terry's disciples
the dad's organ
like her dad's unite
my dad actually carries disciples in
gutter cleaning
i love you
and the one guy is like all right boys
are you thinking what i'm thinking rob a
bank get ice cream no
start cooking math meth
oh i just i got a little carried away
with the whole gang thing guys
[Laughter]
we're thinking about driving down a
spring training
i've been lonely since cheryl left
it's just looking to start a game
yeah let's [ __ ] kill someone like
what the [ __ ] john hey yeah i haven't
talked in a while how are you doing so i
was thinking what do you think about
starting a gang
we murder a couple of guys eh
get a little street cred
oh that's pretty good and then i'll
finally get cheryl back
at two-timing [ __ ] you'll know what's
up
oh hi cheryl oh this just me and my gang
this all right this one is from show her
your pud uh
never had a question read did your mom
used to write your last name on all your
stuff in case it was lost or stolen for
example sports equipment school supplies
tags on your clothes etc
i never did that we never had our name
on anything really i feel like you
probably had mr long i'll go to you
first
uh yeah i think
first name though right like this is
ryan yeah
first name
yeah inside your glove or whatever okay
that makes sense
yes i had
henry foley written in
perfect penmanship in sharpie pen
on
thousands of pairs of tidy weighty
underwear sort of a rich guy moving down
please return to it three three three
mainstream and you can't handle that
after that
he's real fit and hard to shop for
please bring him back
sure it kills the move with your high
school girlfriend when you think your
little [ __ ] skivvies off dude on your
name's all numbers
oh [ __ ] these are my brothers god damn
it
they're women's babies write your name
on your underwear what kind of life are
you living where are your full names on
your tidy white house
i know it's [ __ ] up
and there was a moment where it had gone
on too long i do remember
i do remember about to hook up with
somebody and i remember taking my pants
down and just i caught my eye it said
foley right over there
just your family they all share them
your mom your dad everybody's wearing
the same undies is it a pastor vs
foley's
your family crest is on them what's the
fear they get lost at the uh
yeah like where is your underwear off
that much as a kid that's crazy unless
you're going to sex parties or something
no that's someone you go you're right
you go to someone you agree yeah all
right
makes it easier after the orgy you know
what i think that's a real weird dude no
it was your underwear shouldn't come off
as a kid anywhere
it's weird if you leave the house and
then come home without underwear on as a
kid
god damn it henry
again that's [ __ ] strange dude
you don't want the priests wasting their
time
trying to redress you you know what i
mean
it's a business they're running um no
that's you can't be doing that no it was
left over
from like maybe in like 10th grade or
11th grade i went to like lacrosse camp
or something like that so when there's
like a bunch of underwear involved
you know it was just making a great case
for yourself
maybe ninth or ninth grade not junior
year still
he's like listen when you're at college
graduation things get
[Laughter]
things just get a little wacky i do feel
like she did that for my college
underwear too to be honest
well do when you hand them down do you
cross it out and put the other name on
it
property is steve
yeah no that's tough i mean i think we
might have had it with like hockey glove
or a baseball glove or something like
um sure remember like socks and
underwear being in t-shirts i remember
having hand-me-downs equipment with
[ __ ] the name joel a lot of joel no
no this is a family friend
really am i there's some guy that my dad
used to steal from
my dad was a bit of a klepto you know
[Laughter]
joe was always walking on the rink
looking for his stuff
[Laughter]
we just told him what it is we used to
have uh i don't know if you ever did
this but especially for hockey equipment
i played hockey it was so expensive and
somebody sweat i know it was tough but
we had played against sports where you
would go and buy used equipment yeah we
had that like you but like and i
remember being like
like putting like old like ice hockey
pants on us some kid who's probably
pissing himself you know what i mean
just wearing [ __ ] dirty sweaty smelly
equipment it sucked yeah yeah especially
when you're getting everything handed
down like the jock it's like there's a
there's a few things there's a jock
you'll take you'll take uh i think
when i used to play lacrosse i stopped
wearing a jock and i looked back and i'm
like that was crazy but at the time i
was just like you never get hit there i
just [ __ ] couldn't run properly yeah
it was always it was always in the way
and i'm like get this thing the [ __ ] out
of here the cop the cop the jock was
okay it's actually pretty comfortable
but the the cop kills oh what's the
point of the jogger yeah
but you want to feel sexy at work just a
banana hammock at that point a garter
belt what the [ __ ]
those never
those never added up to me anyway what
the jock
they were there was always something
sexual about that there's no need for
that that design that's a little one
with the strap yeah dude i never got it
i wasn't that wasn't just for baseball i
can tell you that
that they should have had to said that
the jock strap it's not just for
basketball ever been to a key party yeah
that's weird man no that's uh i remember
when i was in they came out with shorts
yeah
short like little like kind of booty
shorts or boxers that makes sense
ladies said juicy on the back he made it
sound way less creepy than way more
creepy
all right son here's your booty shorts
it says princess on the back
kevin your coach is here get your booty
shorts on
well you said you didn't want the jock
yeah i never [ __ ] with it really um
all right let's see this is from kyle uh
did you and your family ever stand in
the splash zone of the log flume
you know what i like uh you know yeah
yeah yeah you like stand over the bridge
that was real that was a real dirtbag
family dude that's all that's that's
that is such a home run yeah that's real
dirtbag [ __ ] you're standing there and
he says bonus points if you wore a
poncho
because it was in the beginning of uh
step by step
right oh you wouldn't know i think it's
a fuse yeah i know exactly what you're
talking about that scene's been done
yeah
that's hacked [ __ ]
yeah that was real [ __ ]
real cool if you got soaked is it is are
you answering yes i'm waiting for you to
answer my family not my family as a kid
you were probably like yeah you know
let's go get splat i did that for sure i
don't think my i don't think [ __ ]
denise was standing there with her purse
we all did it that was a part of i
remember a specific time going to great
adventure with our families
okay with our cousins and stuff and that
was we that was a part of the ride as
far as i was concerned you went first
and stood there everybody got splashed
maybe somebody took a picture and then
you went and got in line and got on the
ride and then stole the picture instead
of paying the five yeah
they want to get right at the top you
grab the camera
you get a bit of a scheme together were
you a picture family would they buy the
picture at the uh
yeah i don't think we're buying them
pictures i think they're probably
snapping some photos personally but we
used to have a photographer that
traveled with us
we had a toby that followed us
you know we had a we had a producer
amy leibowitz followed us around for a
little while
um went to the park i've done the splash
can't didn't wear the poncho
okay yeah that poncho is a tough look
i've never done
i've never gotten a picture from a
roller coaster
we would look at them but i don't think
they were ever springing for the picture
really not in the frame that's real
trash you see the the desk like the
attendant gets mad if you try to take a
picture of your with your cell phone
cutting into their profits yeah they get
pissed like just put that down you're
like it's a buddy it's like bringing
your own you're not you're not getting
the money shut the [ __ ] up bringing your
own popcorn into the movie which do you
do do you see my own popcorn no one can
make popcorn you'd be a piece of [ __ ]
yeah do you sneak your snacks in i bring
my sandwiches in
a couple of burritos
i go hey you guys have a microphone my
microwave
you might have thrown us
popping this jamaican patty in there for
a second hey can we throw this in the
airfryer real quick
more of a bring the booze into the
theater guy okay i don't mind i've done
that a couple of times
they don't sell booze uh i've gotten
really drunk and going to the movies but
then like that hangover kicks in around
the second act and you're like mine
kicks in around the second movie because
i'm a double feature guy
what do you mean you're a double female
we just talked about you pay a ticket
and you don't leave until they kick you
out we just talked about this on patreon
actually because t-bone sounds like
catherine hepburn t-bone guy i'm a
double feature man t-bone got caught
will you time it out
all right there's an 11-15
that finishes at one and then the next
movie i want to see starts i have to
time it out yeah is that always your
plan do you is do you usually know
once in a while you go with people that
want to do that so a lot of times you're
it's a hard sell for the people that
just sat through a two-hour movie you're
like well what are we doing next there's
an 8 15 of uh happy p3 we can make it's
like what that started 10 minutes ago
what are you talking about this was the
event dude what happened yeah yeah
marshall guys let's never let this
knight in no talk about a guy who
doesn't know when to wrap it up yeah
marshall hit that exit door all right
we're doing a third place you know what
you know what are all that this is when
i was like
14 or whatever right we used to go to
the this is the movie scam so if like
six of us were there and you there was
so you buy the ticket and then you walk
down the stairs and then there's an
escalator up right okay or no so oh yeah
so that's what it was yeah so then we'd
buy
uh
two tickets or one or one ticket oh
there's two different scams now i got it
one ticket the guy goes through and
sends the one ticket up on the escalator
to the next on the escalator that's
pretty good i'm pretty
or you do it two tickets where one
person keeps coming out and giving the
other ticket but that depends on the
theater you know so they don't all have
escalators but if it's a perfect
scenario the escalator you wrap it in
something send it up the escalator and
then the next guy comes down and sends
it out none of this is recent behavior
obviously right this is oh this is my
like late 20s yeah late 20s [ __ ] two
three years ago
pretty pandemic at least
now this is uh this is 14 13. yeah now
obviously the girl pays i don't really
have any of this
because i i i might have mentioned this
before but i could never figure out why
i remember one time we went to a
drive-through or drive-in again with my
whole both both of our families are like
three families and we have like 20
people right to drive through in the 80s
it was probably a dollar to get in my my
one aunt they had my one aunt tucked
down
and we put a blanket over i mean a woman
can't be done the bill's going to be 40
anyway what what i don't know why we did
it yeah i think we did it just to just
to feel alive or whatever the [ __ ] they
were the rush
but i remember i remember questioning
that like what what are we doing
that's also cray out i mean also that
she's the one that you know the oldest
lady yeah why don't you put two kids
under the floorboard or something you
make some [ __ ] some old lady with a
hunchback creep down get in the glove
compartment
nanny get the
[Laughter]
feature
oh it's definitely we said there we used
to have a joke where we go has anyone
ever done a triple feature oh one guy
didn't live to tell the tale
i mean dude that's six hours in there
came out couldn't close his eyes
i tell you what you got
i'm in 60 man i'm freaking out every
time you wave to him he hits the deck
you're walking around mcdonald's asking
for refill on popcorn
[Music]
that's some good stuff
i remember one time we were smoking weed
and we went to the movies and we got we
were like all right movie starts in 15
minutes and we it was like when you just
started smoking weed so we like you ran
outside smoked weed
in someone's car and then
we got too high and missed that movie
and so we went in we're like oh well the
next one starts in a half hour let's go
out we smoked more weed and then missed
that we missed like four [ __ ] movies
from getting too high in the backseat of
like an oldsmobile just the whole run of
the english patient
first two weeks gone
i just remember like trying to like like
you lose it was like you lost all
concept of time like did we do this how
long have we been here what the [ __ ]
happening
i could never really do that casually
smoke weed no we didn't we we weren't
able to do the things that sucked
yeah we're so worried kids today will
never know how panicked it was back then
you were panicked yeah especially man i
felt like the it was the feds that were
going to be closing in on us
and then there was always a couple kids
that were like yeah i just [ __ ]
smoked a big blunt and went to school
yeah
yeah yeah who is this guy he's even
human i know this guy yeah here terry
was smoking this morning like what the
[ __ ] yeah i would have a massive panic
attack
yeah
pills hit when we were in high school
and i mean dude there was dudes [ __ ]
talking about dropping inhibitions oh my
god i remember i think i might have said
this i heard one of my buddies took 10
uppers and 10 downers at the same time
just to see if they would cancel out
he got carted out before lunch time that
[ __ ] kid on a show but got 1600 on
this 18
24 though
pretty good
all right let's see this one's from lee
i would assume you have done this for
sure foley no way in hell ever play on a
trampoline with a skateboard deck that
didn't have trucks or wheels on it come
on yeah you know i already know what it
is
that was [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that didn't
have trucks or something it's just the
deck
and what are you doing you're still
doing your little tricks
i'm bringing bmx bikes with no wheels on
the tram that was always there was one
kid in the town store that you heard
about that with no wheels wouldn't you
puncture it no people would do that they
would like put some sort of like
you know like a skateboard deck on the
fork so it was like flat and then you
could do like tail whips and [ __ ] let me
ask you this in that situation doesn't
it throw off the weight of the
skateboard like how can you do your
little no no you're thinking it's more
about the tricks it's more about the
like grab tricks you know what i mean
think of it more like snowboarding
almost so you can do kickflips and stuff
but it's more like do a backflip and
[ __ ] you're holding the board the
whole time i got you okay turn yourself
into sean white up there
the flying tomato i was gonna say the
big tomato
here comes the big tomato lighter
skateboard now you're doing quad kick
flips like a damn ball exactly yeah we
did all that [ __ ] for sure we used to do
it with the wheels before we realized
you could just use the deck and
sometimes you would land and [ __ ]
this thing would shoot dude my body got
shot off broke his arm three places off
a trampoline like a bone popping out
armor you were a trampoline kid huh yeah
a little bit of a trampoline okay well
when they hit a trampoline you got it
written all over you jack we had to take
trampoline at like
his apartment
trampoline at school yeah
dude we had a trampoline like class what
are you a russian gymnast what the [ __ ]
takes trampoline i'm not kidding
yeah it was like part of gym doing
trampoline yeah it's like an ocean's 12
school
and i got to hide in this box yeah i
know we had that and then we had bomb
diffusion
after lunch and learn how to handle
plutonium you know
ah missing drone class god damn it
that's crazy what do you mean as a part
of jim yeah then you have to you know
then after after you got detention
you're holding your breath class you
know
and then [ __ ] out the key
[Laughter]
what was the class there just no jim
this is like elementary school not high
school we had this is how we grew up in
the suburbs it was like developing
outside of the city and we had we had uh
not line dancing but
country dancing country square dancing
square dancing we had square dancing
classes that was like on an audio tape
it was like now press stop and [ __ ] like
dosie doe and stuff
it was a tough look i remember us
getting that little kid us getting
caught up with a huge parachute for way
too long of the year parachute what was
that about when they broke that thing
out and you they would pop it up and
then play under it that was a human as
well been in another dimension that was
good [ __ ] taking molly
[ __ ] sandstorm starts playing once
you got under that parachute too
anything goes you know it's good for the
local pervert of the town there's just a
grown guy in there all right everyone in
the park yeah he goes in there
don't forget your underwear this time
henry
was a free-for-all without paris you
went up
it's like hungry hungry hippo
this is crap just keep grabbing them up
as they come out oh that'd be [ __ ] up
that was a good time though we're gonna
add some of the parachute this year kids
we're gonna put four known pedophiles
good luck
just to prove that this game is safe
um do you ever drop off a trampoline
into a pool
uh no never had a pool near the tram any
jackassee type uh stunts because i could
say
that was my whole [ __ ] thing when i
was younger
less jackassy and more what's the most
powerful
stuff like that to you yeah but again it
was way
way less stunty yeah we would still do
that stuff and we had a couple buddies
like you know i had one body that would
he used to be able to chug a full thing
a [ __ ] uh
like
like a 26er of uh
whiskey or whatever then he'd break a
skateboard over his head that's a trick
that used to come out a lot oh my god a
lot of people jumping off high places
all that sort of [ __ ] whatever but the
main thing was way more about like going
getting kicked out of all the places and
all that sort of stuff filming like
stealing the parents car and then doing
his who could do the most point turn in
front of a city bus
just like [ __ ] doing the awesome
powers thing yeah the mr b
that's pretty good i'll give you that
that's pretty good
that's pretty good hijinks right there
that's not hurting anybody that's good
so you're a little late for work give
the kids some credit a little canadian
mayhem huh yeah
[ __ ] i would love to get out of the way
you hoser
i gotta get the trampoline class let's
go steal pens from the bank
[Laughter]
i'm gonna take two lollipops i said suri
but i didn't mean it
wouldn't it be a hoot if we signed up
for dancing lessons then did them
we'll show those bozos
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's pay with cash when we actually had
the
[Laughter]
[Applause]
card no i don't have exact chance
dory
sorry
[Laughter]
i got two nickels right here you're
gonna have to break that five
god damn it
that's a [ __ ] hoot right now we did
kill a guy though
he had it coming
all right i'm ryan long welcome to funny
things we do when we film it
welcome to acting like a horses we're
playing we fighted we invited johnny
over to play mini sticks and he doesn't
know that we already played earlier
we're going to film the whole thing and
get them
[Laughter]
they're going to murder my mother's bird
you take the curve of the mini stick and
just [ __ ] widen it out a little bit
yeah we flattened out the curve on his
uh
he's got a flat stick you know
[Laughter]
we replaced all the scissors in the
house with lefties welcome back to
knuckleheads today we're going to fix my
dad my stepdad that had to be a [ __ ]
show knuckleheads wait i redo the
interior of my mom's house
we're going to update it see the look on
her face
all right let's do one or two more we
gotta get out of there this has been i'm
gonna replace my mom's uh old plaid
shirt with a brand new plaid shirt
[Laughter]
she deserves it she works hard you know
she really is she really here single mom
i was kind of scottish i went into oh
you always go to disguise whenever you
do canadian yeah i mean i think i can
only do scottish because you're doing
the classic canadian like oh yeah like
that like you're doing the island
canadian if you want to do the island
everyone actually does you do the more
like [ __ ] ride eh just [ __ ] rip
and darts darts buddy yeah like the
pavone that put the pavone's a mix of
italian and canadian yeah smoking darts
buddy yeah
this guy's got a nice head of lettuce on
him yeah you're right because he does
say the same things but it's a little
more he's just a little more his hands
involved because he's right the
canadians like body and all the bones
like body body what are you doing
did you get the italian influence in the
canadian but that old one like that
that's way more of the islands
the islands
that's the yeah the east coast yeah yeah
the real the [ __ ] real like small
town [ __ ] boys it's more about this
[ __ ] hatchet yeah yeah smoking darts
is good too darts are already arts is a
good time darts is good i'll give you
another stars is a great name
marbles and [ __ ] up there no they oh no
marbles but they do have other things
you gotta you gotta you gotta get marble
bills from a guy really gotta talk i
don't know i gotta talk to an american
guy he used to be a big thing someone go
on the trip to america they have to take
the orders for people come back with the
good darts you know
doing that across state lines is [ __ ]
trash oh i love it it's going through
customs that's cool the real trash is
the res rockets my body used to go to
the [ __ ] pockets what's the reason
this guy's smoking res rackets you go to
their native reserves they don't pay
taxes you get a [ __ ] plastic bag full
of cigarettes
just and you're using someone else's hey
let me know when you're done with that
pack
filling up your own zigs in a pack yeah
we need a guy that used to tour with us
that just have a big plastic ziploc bag
full of i feel like you lose this or i
knew this that's that maybe he's done
the show known where do they get where
do they talk about starts
where do they get this why are they
lucy's you go to the because i mean you
buy them from the reserve and it's not a
big company it's some guy that rolled
them oh really bro he just said that
three seconds i thought i thought they
just sold them on there
i thought they were major companies that
just sold them through no i don't think
you paid taxes is the idea like yeah i
thought they got like the like the the
leftovers are like four that didn't fit
it might be it's like pj maxx
that's what i thought that's what i
thought we get all of your regulars the
ones with the stains at them
a couple of res rackets you know i mean
this one's extra long but it's actually
got
[Laughter]
you know you're not supposed to do
lucy's the place by my house like sells
people lose cigarettes and they have a
lighter that's taped to a string for i
thought that that's that's when you know
that a bad neighborhood you know you
know shittier neighborhood will sell you
lucy's in a really bad neighborhood you
can smoke inside inside the bodega or at
least light it and make it
also too i like the i like finding a
place the place in my uh neighborhood
has the ten dollar cigs where they come
from a different state they ship them up
from like georgia or whatever where
they're
yeah virginia i bought a pack i bought a
pack at [ __ ] 7-eleven or something
the other day and they charged me 17 for
a pack of cigarettes you believe these
kids they're getting up there need a
couple of res rockets
uh all right screeching halt uh
hanging for the purdue thing
[Laughter]
i ripped on the chickens with purdue
fair enough um all right this one's from
cousin jeffrey ever been to a ripley's
believe it or not
i have in canada for dinner or at
niagara falls i don't know what side it
was niagara falls is a big yeah i've
been to all that stuff
what is inside there guinness book of
world records type [ __ ] right like the
stories behind it but the thing is and
and a lot of uh wax sculptures of you
know a guy so it's like
they're like connected i think it's the
same guy who like takes they're always
next to each other if you ever notice at
any like shitty strip mall or what
they're not stripping i mean the guy
that did the show what was his name
those things are a fun rip though to go
on a date you know what you mean you go
with your chick and you get drunk and
rip around and see the bearded lady
i've never i've
no i just walked by the madame tussauds
on 42nd street the other day and there's
they have a jimmy fallon out front that
like looks nothing like jimmy fallon
it looks like they spit him out of the
east river it does not look like him
and that's on the display yeah that's
like the first thing and i'm like
mob hit jimmy fallon what are you
talking about get in line all right we
gotta wrap it up gang gang we love you
been a hot one we love you
thank you for coming in uh anything you
want the folks out there to know you got
coming up what's the scoop
the main thing is check out the podcast
i do every friday cast and uh
patreon.com
the boys cast and i do sketches every
monday and i'm releasing the stand-up
special next month actually ah
congratulations brothers awesome where'd
you film it at the stan
nice oh very nice almost done i'm
editing it nice gang check that out
kippy you got anything for him uh check
out our special live shows the whole
[ __ ] nine yards uh i'm just special
by the way appreciate it thank you very
much uh yeah guys that camera comedy on
all social media cool real quick t-bone
with the weather
that's it guys have a good night peace